Now that we've taken a look at the simple IK rig, we're going to see how the full
body IK or FB IK within control rig compares, seeing why you'd use this and when it's
a good idea to do so, and we'll cover the steps on how you might set one up for your
own character.
So what is the full body IK system or FB IK in Unreal Engine?
Well the concept behind the system is exactly the same as the simple IK rig, so it is designed
as a procedural adjustment tool, but this time to be used within control rig to give
you an alternative solution for things like ground alignment or arm reaching behaviour.
And as with the simple IK rig, some of the primary reasons to use FB IK are things like
maintaining contact, so keeping your feet on the ground or your hands on the table for
example.
You can also dynamically change the height of your character, so you can force them to
crouch by lowering the hips while their feet remain planted.
And it's great for reaching a target like with the IK goals in the simple IK rig, adjusting
the hand position for example when pressing a button.
So now that we kind of understand that if it's designed to work in a similar way to
the simple IK solution, then why would we use this over any of the other IK systems
in the engine?
Well, there are a few reasons for that.
With the FB IK solution within control rig, you get a greater range of motion and there
are more settings available to you to tune your output pose.
So when using a single chain IK, if you reach the end of the chain length, the goal can
no longer be reached and the chain will just lock up.
And when using FB IK you can engage the whole body to move the route and reach those goals.
It also has multiple effectors, so there may be times when you need multiple contact points
to be maintained at the same time or even at different times, which may only be possible
if the solver is allowed to move the route of the character.
And when it comes to the torso or spine of your character, if you're using a single
IK chain, you can't guarantee a great spine pose, so using a full body IK system to engage
the whole body is going to give your character a much better final pose.
When you're using the FB IK system within control rig, remember that it's something
that is meant to operate on top of your existing animation and not generate something from
scratch, so you can't expect it to fix bad inputs or bad posing.
If your rig scenario doesn't require a full body IK system, do continue to just use single
IK chains because there's no sense in having a full body system running if it's not necessary.
And as with any IK setup, don't start with perfectly straight limbs.
Make sure that things like your elbows and your knees have a slight bend in them so that
the IK solver can calculate the default bending direction correctly.
Something to try and avoid as well is to increase the iterations that the solver has performed
to compensate for any bad setup.
Make sure to just take your time adjusting the settings to suit your character, giving
you the output pose that you want.
And make sure never to pull your character outside of the capsule, because this will
likely end up with your character misaligning from their collision and could cause things
like your character going through walls and other meshes.